[Music]
in the 16th century the mathematician
Robert record wrote a book called the
whetstone of wit to teach English
students algebra but he was getting
tired of writing the words is equal to
over and over his solution he replaced
those words with two parallel horizontal
line segments because the way he saw it
no two things can be more equal could he
have used four line segments instead of
two of course could he have used
vertical line segments in fact some
people did there's no reason why the
equal sign had to look the way it does
today at some point it just caught on
sort of like a meme more and more
mathematicians began to use it and
eventually it became a standard symbol
for equality math is full of symbols
lines dots arrows English letters Greek
letters superscripts subscripts it can
look like an illegible jumble it's
normal to find this wealth of symbols a
little intimidating and to wonder where
they all came from sometimes as record
himself noted about his equal sign there
is an apt conformity between the symbol
and what it represents another example
of that is the plus sign for addition
which originated from a condensing of
the Latin word ette meaning and
sometimes however the choice of symbol
is more arbitrary such as when a
mathematician named Christian cramp
introduced the exclamation mark for
factorials just because he needed a
shorthand for expressions like this
in fact all of these symbols were
invented or adopted by mathematicians
who wanted to avoid repeating themselves
or having to use a lot of words to write
out mathematical ideas many of the
symbols used in mathematics are letters
usually from the Latin alphabet or Greek
characters are often found representing
quantities that are unknown and the
relationships between variables they
also stand in for specific numbers that
show up frequently but would be
cumbersome or impossible to fully write
out in decimal form
sets of numbers and hole equations can
be represented with letters two other
symbols are used to represent operations
some of these are especially valuable as
shorthand because they condense repeated
operations into a single expression the
repeated addition of the same number is
abbreviated with a multiplication sign
so it doesn't take up more space than it
has to a number multiplied by itself is
indicated with an exponent that tells
you how many times to repeat the
operation and a long string of
sequential terms added together is
collapsed into a capital Sigma these
symbols shorten lengthy calculations to
smaller terms that are much easier to
manipulate
symbols can also provide succinct
instructions about how to perform
calculations consider the following set
of operations on a number take some
number that you're thinking of multiply
it by two subtract one from the result
multiply the result of that by itself
divide the result of that by three and
then add one to get the final output
without our symbols and conventions we'd
be faced with this block of text with
them we have a compact elegant
expression sometimes as with equals
these symbols communicate meaning
through form many however are arbitrary
understanding them is a matter of
memorizing what they mean and applying
them in different contexts until they
stick as with any language if we were to
encounter an alien civilization they'd
probably have a totally different set of
symbols but if they think anything like
us they probably have symbols and their
symbols may even correspond directly to
ours they'd have their own
multiplication sign symbol for pi and of
course equals if you enjoyed this lesson
we think you enjoy learning more about
one of our favorite mathematical symbols
infinity and if you want ted-ed lessons
delivered straight to your inbox click
the middle button and sign up for our
weekly newsletter thanks for watching